well as angelès alain mabanckou auteur
et professeur de littérature de langue
française à l'université de la
californie il vient de publier rumeurs
d'amérique il ya quelques semaines alain
mabanckou on est très heureux de vous
retrouver j'avoue ça fait quelques jours
ci dans quelques semaines qu'on essaie
de pouvoir vous parler pendant le thabor
delà de votre démarche
ça fait quand même des années que vous
êtes aux états unis vous êtes du congo
brazzaville vous avez vécu en france et
vos rumeurs d'amérique dans le fond vous
retracer les culture ambiante
l'ambiance qui règne aux états unis en
ce moment je pense que j'ai eu la chance
de vivre à la fois à la côte est et à la
côte ouest où je suis actuellement j'ai
vécu dans le michigan le michigan qui
doit vous rappeler quelque chose puisque
c'était un des états les plus prisés
dans cette élection qui le jour de
l'annoncé des premiers résultats donnant
un peu c'était revendiquer propriétaire
entre guillemets avant que ça ne puisse
tourner et avec les mails et puis j'ai
vécu également et je vis également à los
angeles et de rumeurs d'amérique pour
moi est un duo plutôt personnelle
subjective ou j'analyse un peu les
rapports personnels je peux parler de la
vie de tous les jours de la composition
raciale de telle ville mais se vit sous
la forme de ce que je pourrais appeler
une sorte d'autobiographie mais du
continent américain où je me retrouve
aujourd'hui où j'enseigne la littérature
à l'université de la californie los
angeles
ouais est ce que vous êtes étonnés de
ces résultats aussi serrés que trump
exerce encore sur une grande part de
l'électorat même l'électorat racisées
que ce soit les latinos que ce soit les
afro américains
donc qu'ils exercent une telle
fascination et requins quand même plus
de voix que ce qui était envisagé
non je ne suis pas étonné parce que je
suis plutôt étonné que les gens soient
étonnés quand il fait des décennies que
l'amérique est devenue pratiquement
bipolaire hier il ya deux de deux
éléments presque contradictoires
regardez en 2000 on a eu pratiquement la
même scène
il a fallu aller jusqu à recompter les
voir on a failli avoir à ce moment là
debout ce qui allait perdre la
californie qu'il a gagné mais madeleine
plutôt comme ça devant al gore et la
rendent donc gardons la floride excusez
moi et pendant que tout cela se pensait
on s'était dit que bon ça serait
peut-être une amérique qui changerait
mais seulement l'amérique n'a pas vu
venir le nouveau visage
elle devient de plus en plus mélangées
mais plus elle devient bélanger plus
l'aspect blanc de copulent de l'amérique
a l'impression de père de tous les
privilèges qu il faisait 2 jusqu alors
les maîtres du monde
donc moi je pense que ça se joue de plus
en plus sur les jeunes qui aujourd'hui
ont pris conscience du dépassement de la
question raciale et des suprémacistes
blancs puisque 32 représentants en
général l'ensemble des républicains
temple normalement il est même
minoritaire à l'intérieur des
républicains mais les républicains
acceptent la victoire quelques soins et
gagner les élections parce qu'évidemment
on dit toujours que 2 america qu'elle
ait fourni vous êtes monsieur bridenne
une très forte majorité mais pensez vous
avec ce que vous évoquez sur les
questions raciales qu'au fond puisque le
ticket by d'anaïs et temps pas beaucoup
joué là-dessus le canal était dans sa
prononciation président pose pas vrai
que ça va être une femme noire la
première femme présidente des états unis
pensez vous que ça a joué aussi pour
mobiliser non non non je ne pense pas
que ça joue et je pense que ce qui s'est
passé c'est que les démocrates pendant
l'élection de
2016 avait comme une certaine assurance
que hillary clinton allait l'emporter
et n'oublions pas que les démocrates
étaient divisés entre ceux qui
soutenaient berly sanders et ceux qui
soutenaient hillary clinton mais est ce
qu'ils sont mais bernie sanders 9
détester à moi hillary clinton
or - vous allez au bureau des ventes
plus donald pourtant pas la chance or
cette fois-ci les américains qu'ils
s'étaient trompés en tout cas les
progressistes il s'était trompé et qu'il
n'était pas aller aux élections
ils sont allés se sont rajoutés aussi
tous les mouvements sociaux qui sépare
son passé aux états unis
les assassinats les bavures policières
le président qui applaudissaient les
suprémacistes et paiera tout cela ça a
créé une autre dimension
silencieuse presque moi je prédisais
pratiquement ce que ce qui se passait
dans le sens où la première vague serré
donald trump qui l'un des premiers jours
donné l'impression qu'il a gagné tout
simplement parce que il a commis
l'erreur de demander à ses supporters de
n'ai pas voté par correspondance ou
alors par courrier mais d'aller sur
place pour montrer parce que lui il aime
ce qui est visible ce qui montre la
quantité alors que joe boyd elle disait
votez dès maintenant envoyer vos
courriers et voilà qu on détruit on se
rend compte que vous avez cités tout à
l'heure la pennsylvanie vous il était
déjà presque un constat 700000 el-oued
avance voilà les cdd sont des sondés
sont alors elle est devenue trop que
j'ai vu c'était pratiquement dans les 53
50 quelques milles et donc
l'alimentation rétrécit cela dit on se
croirait encore en campagne électorale
je pose est d'accord avec moi mais si
mabanckou comme vous avec la déclaration
de monsieur tron tout à l'heure après 48
heures de silence
il attaque le système électoral les
envoie pas laisser faire ça et se disent
oui on va pas se laisser en voler
l'élection
comment réagissez vous à ça vous ça vous
inspire quoi cette ces attaques de trump
à rendre ces c'est la marque déposée de
donald points il sent que quelque chose
est en train de lui échapper
il ne supporte pas la défaite il ne
supporte pas que que
quelqu'un puisse être dans la lumière
sans qu'il soit là il avait disparu un
moment dans la journée mais entre-temps
jobs est devenu faire un discours
fédérateur en disant que soyez qu'à
laisser les élections selon le comptage
de voix se faire extrader elle a eu une
posture présidentielle et je pense que
donald un peu venu parler même contre le
gré que ses conseillers
puisque quand il est arrivé c'est peu de
dire des choses qui ne sont pas vraies
deux accusés
d'un côté il dit arrêté de compter mais
il dit mais non quand même continuer à
compter dans l'arizona où je suis en
avance mais où je peux non c'est pas
possible donc en congo donald comptes
estime kim d'élections et bornes
lorsqu'il a gagné et les mauvaises
lorsqu'il a perdu et comment des lettres
à lima va quand même de l'être je pense
que vous avez des comparaisons
savoureuses comme par exemple je crois
vous avez mentionné que là ce que trame
fait maintenant c'est un peu comme une
femme de la fontaine racontez nous mais
je pense que dans la fable de la
fontaine il ya une fable dans laquelle
justement le jeu coûte c'était le lion
et le rat
je pense que le rat dormait dans un trou
quelque part et puis le lion avait posé
sa petite patte là et puis de lyon
le rat est sorti le lion ne l'a pas
manger et le répartie et une fois le rat
est arrivé il trouve le lion dans les
filets des humains et le rat s'est
souvenu que les lions qui l'avait
laissée aller il aura à manger seulement
une petite mailles du filet et au fur et
à mesure il a ouvert tout donc audi une
maille ronger emporte à toul ouvrage la
fontaine dit cela mais moi je reverse
cette fable en disant que donald trump
cherche seulement à ronger les mailles
pour ouvrir peut-être le mal ce qu'ils
vont faire mais la société car
j'aimerais dire ouais moi des comptes il
rappelle que vous êtes professeur de
littérature mais aussi vous que vous
avez aussi une belle comparaison pour
les deux camps trempez by day
non je pense que ce expérience
oui on peut aller du côté exprimé
franchement revenir aux réalités qui
sont là que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
puissent voir parfois j'en ai souvent
marre des comparaisons qui sont trop
lointaines et nos jeunes ne comprends
pas prenez simplement l'exemple
on est comme dans le tome du patriarche
de gabriel garcia marquez ou le le roi
ou le président ou le taux cats se sont
invincibles les mêmes continûment il
pense qu'il va continuer à gouverner
c'est un peu cela on est aussi dans la
vie et demi de l'écrivain congolais sony
labou tansi où on pense que le monarque
que va vivre pendant longtemps parce qu'
il a pu gagner n'est latino de la
floride parce qu'il leur a fait peur sur
le communisme qui nous appelaient à la
porte des états unis il a payé des
campagnes dans les radios de la tis
pagny pour cela alors même que c'était
carrément vendre du rêve à ces mêmes
hispanique qu'il critique
il veut construire des murs il ya une
histoire des parents qui ont été
détachés et ces jeunes hispaniques pour
la plupart des cubains afro cubain est
devenu nerfs sont tombés dans ses bras
avec un gouverneur de la floride qui
obéit aux ordres de détroit je pense que
ça serait bien pour l'amérique
maintenant qu'on est l'image d'un père
de famille comme de joe by day - il est
comme ça